ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะค่ะนักเรียนเสียง
หวานไหมคะมากค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงมีเสียงใหญ่สวัสดีค่ะครู
เอ๋ขอเสียงน่ารัก
เขียนวันที่ดีกว่าค่ะตายค่ะวันใครเขียนคะ
หญิงเขียนข้าวอยู่นี่ปากกาพร้อมแล้ว
วันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันอังคารค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
17 ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะ
ดีเดือนพฤษภาคม
ปีพตเท่าไหร่คะ ep นะคะศ.
2565  a ชอบถามปีที่เท่าไหร่
หายได้ค่ะพี่มีอะไรโอเคปีที่เท่าไหร่โอเค
อาปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2
022 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงตอนนี้เวลา
4:40 นาทีค่ะครูเอ๋ 40 นาทีนะคะ
ใต้ค่ะวันนี้กูหญิงมีอะไรวันนี้ครูหญิง
นี่มีคำถามมั้ยเอามีคำถามผู้หญิงถามครู
เอ๋ตอบใช่ค่ะ
ครีมมีคำถามถามมีรูปไร่เอาไปยุโรปคือ
ก็มีรูปข้างในอาจจะเป็น
เป็นรูปสัตว์นะคะ
ผู้หญิงถามครูเอ๋ถามนักเรียนด้วยไหมคะนัก
เรียนตอบได้ก็โอเคค่ะนักเรียนมาค่ะแล้ว
แล้วกัสตอบข้างล่างซ้ายหรือว่านักเรียนดู
วีดีโอฟังครูหญิงถามนักเรียนก็ตอบได้มา
นักเรียนตอบกับครูเอ๋นะคะ
ทรายเข้าเคค่ะวันนี้รอดู
จริงๆอันนี้ครูเอ๋เนี่ยเก่งนะคะคำถามที่
กูหญิงจะถามวันนี้เนี่ยผู้หญิงพูดแล้วแต่
นั้นกูเองผิดจริงแล้วอะ
เอ้าครูเอ๋ครูเอ๋เนี่ยกูเห็นชอบกูเป็นคน
ชอบ
อีสัตว์ยาเนี่ยสาวขอโอเค
สิงโต
วานกบเนี่ยสัตว์ครูเอ๋ชอบครูหญิงไม่ชอบ
กูเอลเอไม่ได้ชอบครั้งหมดนะ
แต่ตัวเองรู้จักไงคะรู้จักนะที่แล้วกีฬา
ที่คู๋
เย้เพลงฮูประมาณ 95 เปอร์เซ็นต์ค่ะ
วันนี้สัตว์เนี่ยแต่ครูหญิงจะถามครูเอ๋
เกี่ยวกับ
กบอันเนี้ยกบกินอะไร
นั่นแหละมิมี
ABC ไหมจริงมีแค่ 2 เท่านั้นนะคะพูดเอ๋
หรออย่างเงี้ยอ๋อ
ก็เพราะว่าสัตว์เนี่ยใช่ไหมคะสัตว์พวกนี้
เนี่ยมันจะแบ่งใหญ่ๆเนี่ยประมาณ 3  3 ค่ะ
ก็คือ 1 สัตว์กินเนื้อใส่ค่ะอันนี้สัตว์
กินเนื้อ
2 สัตว์กินพืช
ชัยค่ะ 3 สัตว์กินเนื้อแล้วก็กินพืชตาย 3
ก็คือคือหนึ่งบวกสองลหคือคนใช่ไหมคะไม่
ใช่คนคนสกลกินเนื้อแล้วก็กินพืชใช่แต่
เสือเสือในรูปเนี่ยเสือเป็นสัตว์กินเนื้อ
นอนเสือกินพืชไม่ได้ไม่กินไม่เสือไม่กิน
กินอัดจะกินแต่ไม่อิ่มชายค่ะกระต่าย
กระต่ายก็กินพืชนะคะให้ไม่รู้โอ้นี่เห็น
ไหม Choice มี 3 ว่าเป็นสัตว์กินพืชสัตว์
กินเนื้อสัตว์กินเนื้อสัตว์กินพืชหรือ
สัตว์กินเนื้อแล้วก็เป็นสัตว์กินพืชไม่
ง่ายคุยดิใส่ผู้หญิงกำลังเช็ค Google นัก
เรียนไม่ง่ายอันนี้ยากค่ะครูครู
เอ๋เดี๋ยวบอกผู้หญิงสต๊อกนะเห็นต้องแชร์
อีก 1 อัน
ผู้เอกคิดไม่ง่ายนะคะคุณหญิง
เดี่ยวคู่เอกขอเบรคไปไปดู YouTube ดู
Google ก่อนได้ไหมคะไม่ได้ค่ะครูเควสขีด
โอเค
ไม่เป็นไรด้วยนะนักเรียนช่วยครูเอ๋ด้วยนะ
คะอ่ะมาดูที่สัตว์ตัวแรกเลยค่ะอ่าอะไรคะ
ครูเอ๋เอ๋
และวัวค่ะ
ผู้หญิงสอนครูฟ้าดูฟ้าก็พูดดูๆไม่ได้นะก็
เรียนรู้วัวมั้ย
นักเรียนตัวนี้มี 3 มี 2 ชื่อ 3 แบบอะไร
บ้างครูเอ๋งวัวนะงูวัวหมูป่ากูดีนะกูวัว
วัวค่ะอันนี้ชื่อที่ 1 ชื่อที่ 2 โคค่ะ 2
ชื่อแต่คนไทยบางจังหวัดพูดวัวไม่ได้แล้ว
งัวอา
งูอ่ะเนี่ยเปลี่ยนเป็นไงอ่ะงูๆนะแต่ไม่
ได้ผิดนะเขาแค่พูดวัวไม่ได้เขาเขาได้
เสียงเพี้ยนนะคะๆนะอ๋อไม่ใช่ชลบุรีเท่า
นั้นมีหลายๆจังหวัดง่วง
แต่ตอนเด็กๆคุยก็เคยได้ยินนะคะแต่บ้านเขต
จะแล้ววัวนะอ้าวครูเอ๋ครูเอ๋คิดว่าวัว
เป็นสัตว์กินเนื้อสัตว์กินพืชกูอยากจัง
เลยหรือทั้งสองอย่างเออนี่แหละ
คือนักเรียนกินพืชกินเนื้อโอเคกิน 2
อย่างเนี่ย
ผมมีผมคุณครูเอเชื่อตัวเองตัวเองเห็นปุ๊บ
คิดอะไรเชื่อตัวเองเคยเห็นค่ะกินพืชค่ะ
ครูบอกว่าวัวเป็นสัตว์กินพืชไปดูเฉลยนะคะ
ว่าใช่ไหมเฉลยเฉลย
ใช่ค่ะอ่าแม่เพราะว่าวัววัวกินหญ้าหาคน
จะกินด้านนะคะ
ตอนนี้คนกินด้า
[เพลง]
จะ
เอาแบบส่วนใหญ่น้ำมันไม่ใช่เป็นคือถ้า
ต้องกินทั้งพืชกินทั้งเนื้อก็คือมันกิน
เหมือนคนเหมือนคน
กินเนื้อเนื้อค่ะครูเอบอกว่าสิงโตเป็น
สัตว์กินเนื้อหากินเหมือนเสือใช่มั้ย
เหมือนเสือเสือกินอะไรเนี่ยสิงโตค่ะ
ไปดูเฉลยนะคะครูเอ๋กินอะไรสิงโต
เพลง
ขอกินแอนทีโลปหรอคะไม่รู้ดิ
ถึงมากชื่ออะไรสปริงบอกป่ะอันโฉลกที่กู
เองพูดนั่นแหละค่ะแต่ผู้หญิงไปดูในภาษา
ไทยเขาเรียกอะไรลำมั่ง
ละมั่งหรอไม่ใช่ไม่รู้เหมือนกันขอ
คือคือนักเรียนค่ะจะมีตัวนี้จะมี 2  Group
จะมีเดียวคือควางโอ้โห้ High เออไม่
เหมือนกันยังไงคุยลืมแต่มันจะเห็นโลกที่
เป็นแบบนี้ชื่อสปริงบอก
พอแต่จะจับลิงบอกจะมีข้างหลังเพราะอันนี้
ล่ะมั้งของไทยใช่ไหมคะอืมน่าจะไม่ใช่ของ
ไทยมั้งคะผู้หญิงเสิร์ชคำว่า and  Heroes
แล้วมันก็ขึ้นรูปนี้มาอันนี้ไม่ได้มาจาก
Google ไง and ที่โล่งดีหลายๆตัวจาก
สิงโตกินนะจริงสิงโตกินหลายๆอย่างทุก
อย่างค่ะใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าสิงโตนะกินเนื้อ
เหมือนเสือไหมเสือเป็นสัตว์กินเนี้ยนะ
เก่งมากค่ะครูเอกต่อไปอ่ะตอนนี้กินอะไรคะ
ผู้หญิงไม่มีค่ะ
ผู้หญิงคิดว่ากินพืช
ใช่มั้ยเหมือนเพราะกระต่ายกินพืชเพราะว่า
กวางกินพืชเนี่ยอ้าติด
ต่อใบนะคะกูเอ๋
หมูๆน่ารักอันนี้กู a นะคะว่าสีชมพูใช่
ค่ะวันนี้เรียนตกใจ
ถ้าไม่สีดำกูหญิงค่ะผู้ระบุตัดครูหญิงค่ะ
เลยไม่ต้องตกใจนะคะครูหญิงว่ากูเอ๋ถ้า
บุรินทร์บุรินทร์ในคู๋นะคะรายจ่ายแต่ถ้า
คุโรบุตะนี้ผู้หญิงนะคะคุยอร่อยกว่านะ
แข่งกันดิอ่าขี้ครูเอ๋เนี่ยเป็นคนสมัย
ก่อนเนาะผู้หญิงก็พ่อแม่คุยก็คนคิดมาก
ก่อนพูดว่าหมูไม่โกรธๆสายผู้หญิงโอเคค่ะ
ไม่เป็นไรนะคะงูจำน่ารักน้องเนี่ยหมูครู
เอ๋เอ๋คิดว่าหมูหมูเป็นสัตว์กินเนื้อ
เหมือนเสือ
สติลพืชเหมือนกระต่ายหรือเต็มถัง 2 อย่าง
อันนี้ยาก
นักเรียนอนุญาตหมูเนี่ย
กินผักหมูเนี่ยกินรำ
หมูก็กินข้าวด้วย
[เพลง]
ครูคิดว่าอะไรอะไรอะไรมาคิดสองอย่างหรือ 1
อย่างสองอย่างเลยหนึ่งอย่างเออโอเคค่ะกิน
พืชค่ะช่วยหมูเป็นสอนกินพืชเฉลยนะคะถ้ามา
กินเพื่อนก็จะมีรูปเดียวนะคะครูเอ๋กินพืช
กิน 2 อย่างคือ 1  2  3
กิน 2 อย่าง
จริงปะจริงขลุ่ยลองไปดูในอินเตอร์เน็ตได้
เลยแต่มันไม่ได้กินปลาแบบนี้ดีนะมันต้อง
เป็นปลาแบบนี้แล้วก็เอาไปบ่นบ่นๆเป็นผงผง
เฮ้ออยากกินปูกินกุ้งเข้าไปนะสายแล้วก็
กินเข้าหมู
เข้าโทษหรือว่าต้นไม้ถ้าข้าว
ที่บ้านครูเอ๋เมื่อก่อนมีหมูไงกินกล้วย
กินข้าวกินผักบุ้ง
อเวนเจอร์สตาเลี่ยนน่ะครูหญิงก็คิดว่าหมู
หมูเป็นสัตว์กินพืชเหมือนกระต่ายแต่พอ
เช็คเอาหมูกินแบบอาหารหมูหมูไทยนะหมูไทย
กินทุกอย่างอ่ะค่ะวิ่งคือคู่เอกกำลังคิด
ว่าสองอย่างไหมเพราะว่าถ้าเรากินข้าวแล้ว
มีเหลือเราก็ใส่แล้วก็เอาไปให้หมูกินชาย
ใช่แต่ว่าว่าคุณคิดว่าอาหารที่แบบอ่ะหนู
กินมากๆก็คือพวกเป็นอันนี้น้องเป็นกินพืช
in สัตว์กินเนื้อเนี่ยนิดหน่อยนะคะนิด
หน่อยจะได้มีแคลเซียมนะคะหนังโทร in  pics
ต้องเชื่อตัวเองอ่ะต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋ตัวอะไร
คะ
ลิงค่ะมันจะบอกครูเอ๋
พูดนะคะครูเอ๋ตัวเองคิดว่าลิงเป็นสัตว์
กินเนื้อหรือสัตว์กินพืชหรือทั้งสองอย่าง
สองอย่างค่ะแต่ชัวร์หรือเปล่าวัวตัวเอก
เคยเห็นมันหาหาเขา
ไปดูนะถ้าทั้งสองอย่างก็จะเหมือนหมูใช่
ไหมมี 2 รูปให้เราดูเลยเลยเฉลยเฉลย
โอภา
มากกินไข่เอ่อเออนี่อันนี้เป็นไข่นกนัก
เรียน
มันกินไข่นก
ลิงกินเดี๋ยวนี้ลิงกินทุกอย่างนะคะ
แล้วก็กินผลไม้ใช่ไหมคะก็เป็นกินโค้กกิน
เป๊ปซี่ด้วยรักขับรถนะฮะต้องดูดีๆนะฮะถ้า
มีลิงสร้างแต่ว่าลิงเป็นสัตว์ที่กินทั้ง
สองอย่าง
ลิงกับหมูเหมือนเราได้กินทั้งพืชและสัตว์
สนะขาใส่ค่ะต่อไปนะคะครูเอ๋หายเก่งมากเลย
เข้าใจตัวเองนะคะนะ
อะไรมันหลามโอฉลามครูเอ๋คิดว่าฉลามเนี่ย
เป็นสัตว์กินเนื้อเหมือนเสือไม่ได้กิน
เสื่อนะกินเนื้อเหมือนเสือคะหรือว่าเป็น
สัตว์กินพืชหรือจะหรือทั้งสองอย่างกิน
ทั้งเนื้อกินทั้งพืชเอาหลักๆนะคะภู a
อาหารคนที่เห็นนะคะเขียน 1  Hollywood
ฟิล์มเนอะกินเหล้าใช่ไหม
กูเอกคิดว่ากินเนื้อค่ะตัวเอกที่ว่าเป็น
สัตว์กินเนื้อ
หือ
เฉลยกันเลยเฉลยอะลูกข้า
กินปลานาหากินปลานิดทรูนานะกูอีกเสิร์ช
ว่าทูน่า
กำลังตาแบบนี้นักเรียนจะเป็นปลาที่ตัว
ใหญ่
หื้อหายทูน่าคู๋ใหญ่ปลาทูน่าก็ใหญ่นะได้
แล้วเราก็กินทูน่าหน้ากากชีวิมั้ยอะไม่
กินไม่กินคนไทยไม่คุยอีกไม่กินและก็ไม่
กินนะคะ
แล้วทูน่าทูน่ากินเนื้อหรือกินพืชทักครู
เอ๋
ไม่ได้ถามต่อผู้หญิงก็ไม่รู้
เออเออกูเองคิดว่าทูน่าน่ะกินทั้งพืชและ
เนื้อ
ล่าส่วนใหญ่นะคะถ้าไม่ใช่ตัวใหญ่ๆแบบนี้
นะคะเก่งมากค่ะครูเอ๋ต่อไปค่ะ
ตัวอะไรถ้าครูเอ๋
แพะขับแพะร้องยังไงแพ้ๆ
คู๋นะคะ
ครูเอ๋คะครูเอกคิดว่าแพะแพะเป็นสัตว์กิน
เนื้อสัตว์กินพืชหรือทั้งสองอย่าง
อันนี้ไม่ต้องคิดมากนะกินพืชอ่ะครูเอ๋บอก
ว่าแพะแพะที่กินพืชใช่ไหมคะวัว
คิดว่าเฉลยเฉลย
ต้นทองค่ะอาจ
แพ้กินหญ้าใช่ตัวเองเขาเล่นเกมกับซีเรียส
มากและมิชอบแล้วไง
กินยานะคะแพะกินได้มี
โอ้ยกินๆ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ค่าช้างเป็นสัตว์กินเนื้อกินพืชหรือทั้ง
ส่งยางกินพืชค่ะเว้นใจหรอคะมั่นใจค่ะเป็น
สัตว์กินพืชค่ะไม่กินเนื้อเหรอไม่เคยเห็น
เขา
ก็ไม่แน่นะคะกินนมแต่ไม่กินเนื้ออ่ะเฉลย
นะคะทุกๆๆ
พี่ไม่ใช่ช้างเป็นสัตว์กินกินอะไรคะอื้อ
เธอ
ทำให้ฉันกินอ้อยไหมกินกิน in กล้วยโหลกิน
ผลไม้
นะก็กินพืชสมัยช้างเป็นสัตว์กินพืชแต่คู่
หญิงก็กินอ้อยนะคะอร่อยก็เลยเหมือนชาย
ใกล้ๆ TOA
ไงใจหนอติด
ไม่เป็นไรค่ะสีคล้ายๆกันนะคะผู้หญิงคิด
อะไรไม่
ต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋ไปสัตว์
กบอบอกจะไม่ค่อยแน่ใจครูเองคิดว่าเก็บ
เป็นสัตว์กินเนื้อหากินเลี้ยงเหมือนเสือ
นะคะกินพืชหรือดีหรือกินทั้งสองอย่างก็จำ
ไม่ได้นะต้องจะเลยกูเองเคยเห็นกบอ่ะมี
ลิ้นเดียวยาวแล้วก็พูดเวลามีแมลง
กินแมลง Bag ครูเอ๋ไม่รู้กบกินอะไรอีก
กูเอกคิดว่า
เวลาเล็กๆอ่ะกบก็กินแมลงไม่ได้
กิน 2 อย่างค่ะครูเอ๋บอกว่ากบที่กินทั้ง
เนื้อแล้วก็กินทั้งพืชนะคะอะเหลย
สัตว์กินเนื้อ
นัดกบตัวเล็กๆยังไว้น้ำเป็นปลากินอะไรอ่ะ
หนู
กินเนื้อเหมือนกันเหรอเอามันก็มีอะไร
เนี่ยเป็นเขาเรียกอะไรอ่ะแบ่งต้นเธอไข่
ยุงอะไรอย่างนั้นน่ะอ๋อตัวเล็กๆทราย
นี่คือตัวอะไรคุยรู้ไหมคะจิ้งหรีดค่ะไม่
รู้ว่าถ้าผู้หญิงดูรูปนี้ไม่เข้าใจนะคู๋
รู้จักแต่กูเองไม่รู้ว่ากินอะไรอ่ะไม่ได้
กบเนี่ยกินแมลงใช่ไหมจิงหรีดเป็นแมลงก็จะ
มีดีเนาะ
หน้ากูอยากกินจิ้งหรีดไหมคะไม่กินค่ะพี่
ก็คิดถึงเขาให้เค้าจะมีคนให้ค่ะอร่อยนะคะ
ส่อไปค่ะเดี๋ยวได้ๆเหนียวผู้หญิงไม่กิน
ทำไมกูหญิงรู้อร่อยอ๋อเห็นคนกินบอกอร่อย
ขออีกไอ้กินเหม็นนะขอโทษด้วยคนที่ชอบนะคะ
เวลาเขามาทำอะค่ะอ่ะต่อไปนะคะคุยค่ะ
หมีหมี
อันนี้นะคะหมีอะไรเนี่ยมีแบบนี้นะที่
ตัวแบบแล้วค่ะอ่าฉะนั้นไม่เล่นแบ๊คแบบอะ
อะผู้ชายไม่ใช่หมีไม่ใช่ polar  Bear นะ
ไม่ใช่หมีขั้วโลกนะคะหมีอย่างนี้นะหมี
เป็นสัตว์กินเนื้อเหมือนเสือกินพืชเหมือน
กระต่ายหรือกินทั้ง 2 ภาษา
นักเรียนช่วยกูเอ๋ด้วย
เอออันนี้นี่คิดถึงวินนี่เดอะพูห์ค่ะ
กินน้ำผึ้งอ่ะน้ำผึ้งเนี่ยเป็นเนื้อหรือ
เป็นพื่นเข้าผู้หญิง
พืชนะเราไม่ได้เป็นวีแก้นไงก็ถ้าเป็นแค่
แบบ major เทรียนเนี้ย
เวลาเค้ากินน้ำครึ่งอ่ะมันก็ต้องมีตัว
อ่อนผึ้งด้วยนะไม่รู้
พี่ก็ไม่รู้อีกไม่ได้เป็นหมีพูห์เอ๋เอ่อ
โอเคกิน 2 อย่าง
เร็วว่าหมีเป็นสัตว์น่ากินทั้ง 2 อย่างนะ
กินทั้งเนื้อแล้วก็กินทั้งพืชนะคะไปดู
เฉลยค่ะ
ถูกค่ะครั้ง
ใจหมีเนี่ยอันนี้พี่อ่ะหมีกินมดมันก็กิน
นะคะมีกินคู๋โอเคขอ 1 ตัวเอากลับไปไว้ที่
บ้านป้าหมีน่ารักนะพูดไปนะคะแล้วก็เบอร์
รี่เขาบอกว่าชอบกิน berry
wanna
จ่ายก็กินทั้งสองอย่างใจค่ะกูอีกอยากได้
หมีมาที่บ้านไฟค่ะที่บ้านครูเอ๋มีมดมากๆ
จะให้กิน
ก็มีกินครูเอกนะคะ
ครูเอ๋ไม่มีไม่กินปูเอมี่ตบคู๋อะต่อไปค่ะ
ครูเอ๋
อะไรอ้อมานั่งเครียดเอกคิดว่าม้าเสือเป็น
สัตว์กินเนื้อกินพืชหรือกินทั้งสองอย่าง
กินพืชค่ะกินพืชนะมันเฉลยมันใจใช่ไหมจะมา
ตัวสวยนะคะเฉลย
Google
กินหญ้าม้าตาไงกินหญ้าน้องไม่กินเนื้อหา
เนื้อค่ะแต่เรากินม้า
ฮะไม่กิน
ไม่กินไม่กินครูเอ๋ไม่กินม้ากินค่ะ
ต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋สัตว์ตัวต่อไป
ม้าลายม้าลาย
จะเข้าใจดีนะคะม้าลายคุยคิดว่าเป็นสัตว์
กินเนื้อกินพืชหรือกินทั้ง 2 อย่างนะ
มาช่วยด้วย
ช่วยครูเอหน่อยเร็วด้วยม้าลายกินอะไรคะ
อ๋ออ๋อนักเรียนบอกคุยอะไรกูเอ๋บอกว่ากิน
พืช in พืชโดยนักเรียนชัวร์หรือเปล่ามั่น
ใจเหรอคะมันใจไปดูเฉลยค่ะ
กินพืช
กินหญ้าเพื่อนกันแต่ม้าลายม้าลายก็กินใบ
ไม้นะกินใบไม้ไม่ใช่มั้ยกินไปมามาอย่ากิน
ใบไม้กินกิ่งไม้อย่างเงี้ยกินมาหากินกิน
ใบมาอ่าใส่ค่ะเก่งมากนักเรียนนักเรียน
เก่งมากนักเรียนบอกครูเอ๋ไงนักเรียน 40
มาฝากใกล้ๆ
พอไปค่ะครูเอ๋ล่ะ
พี่ยัต
ยอมแพ้ได้ไหมอันเนี้ย
มีรูปเป็นแบบเรามันเป็นการ์ตูนอ่ะน่ารัก
เนาะเฮ้ยอะไรของจริงเหรอ
อ่ะกลัวตัว
เองคิดว่าปลาหมึกยัดเป็นสัตว์กินเนื้อกิน
พืชหรือว่ากินทั้งสองอย่าง
[เพลง]
ไม่ญาติจริงปะไม่รู้อ่ะจริงๆหรือว่ากิน
สองอย่างหรือกินพืชหรือกินเนื้อ
กินเนื้อค่ะ Great แปลว่าปลาหมึกยักษ์
เป็นสกินเนื้อใช่ไหมคะไงค่ะ
เฉลยใช่ค่ะมันกินปูขอกินมิ่ง
ขอกินปูกุ้งกินปลาตัวเล็กๆนะคะบ่อปลาหมึก
ยักษ์เป็นสัตว์กินเนื้อแต่เรากินปูนะถ้า
เรากินปลาหมึกยักษ์ด้วยนะฮะเราต้องคิดปลา
หมึกยักษ์เก่งมากค่ะครูเอ๋
คุยเรื่องตื่นเต้นแล้วพอคุยอะไรไม่รู้
แล้วต่อไปค่ะ
ตัวอะไรเคยรู้ไหมนกกระจอกเทศหน้าแล้วครู
เอ๋คิดว่านกกระจอกเทศเป็นสัตว์กินเนื้อ
กินพืชหรือกินทั้งสองอย่าง
คุยอยู่แล้วนกกระจอกเทศกินข้าวกินผลไม้
ไม่รู้ด้วยว่าพี่ไม่เคยรู้เลยนกกินอะไร
กินผลไม้คุยกำลังคิดอ่ะค่ะ
คิดว่ากิน 2 อย่างอ่ะครูเอ๋บอกว่านก
กระจอกเทศกินทั้ง 2 อย่างนะกูอะคิดนะกู
เองไม่ชัวร์นะอาบน้ำฮัลโหล
เฉลยกแม่ครูโอ๋ผ่านกินผลไม้เหมือนที่ครู
เอ๋บอกแล้วก็แตกก็บอกว่ามันชอบกินรากไม้
หรอมือแต่ผลไม้ก็กินนะคะพวกเบอร์รี่อะไร
นะกินแล้วก็กินแมลงหวี่แมลง
ชายกินทั้ง 2 อย่างนะกินทั้งพืชกินเนื้อ
หาทั้งสองอย่างนี้คุยเก่งมากเลยอ่ะถ้ากู
หญิงเนี่ยกูจะคิดว่า
กินเหนือผู้หญิงผู้หญิงมักอ่อนเอ๋
The  House พูด
ไม่ต้องคิดเยอะจริงๆน่ะไม่เห็นจระเข้
เนี่ยกินเนื้อแต่ถ้าคุณโยนอะไรเข้าปาก
จระเข้จะให้เราก็กลืนไงเอาแบบว่าจระเข้
กินได้จริงๆไม่ใช่กินแล้วไม่สบาย
อ่า
น่าจะกินได้ 2 อย่างนะค่ะกินเนื้อก็ได้
กินพืชก็ได้แต่มากๆนะกินเนื้อ
อะไร
เลือกค่ะจะเลื่อนกินเนื้อหรือกินทั้งสอง
อย่างแต่ถ้าเธอขี้หาอาหารเองก็ไม่กินพืช
กินเนื้อค่ะหาเจ๊ว่ากินเนื้อจะเริงถูกห้า
มันกินปลา
จระเข้ชอบอ้าปากไงอ่ะก็จะจระเข้กินไก่นะ
ครูเอ๋ที่ที่เราให้กินมันไม่โอเคกับท้อง
จะได้กินเล็กๆนะคะ
อ่ะจะลองกินปลาต่อไปนะคะคุณเอ๋ละเข้มี
เวลามั้ยเนี่ยอุ้ย
โลมาหาฮะโลมาคิดว่าโลมาเป็นสัตว์กิน
เนื้อกินพืชหรือกินทั้งสองอย่าง
ยากรัก
ที่เคยเห็นน่ะโลมากินปลา
8 ที่ทะเลครูเอ๋ไม่รู้โรมาให้กินอะไร
งั้นคูเอกคิดกินปลากินเนื้อค่ะกินเนื้อ
เฉลยนะคะคู๋
ถูกอา
ดีใจกินปลากินปลาหมึกนะปลาหมึกแบบนี้นะคะ
เป็นสัตว์กินเลยเนื้อ
กินปลาหมึกนะคะอันนี้อร่อยนะครับผมยังไม่
อร่อยค่ะอ่าต่อไปค่ะ
[เพลง]
ขีเสื้อ
ผีเสื้อเป็นสัตว์กินเนื้อกินพืชหรือกิน
ทั้งสองอย่าง
ไม่ต้องคิดมากนะ
เอ่อเวลาตอนเป็นหนอนอ้ะกินพืชเวลาเป็น
ผีเสื้อกินน้ำในดอกไม้กินพืชค่ะกินพืช
เฉลยมันสวยหรือไม่รับใช่ค่ะ
กินพืชนะคะกินที่เวทพูดเนาะน้ำหรือว่าน้ำ
หวานในดอกไม้
มีอีกไปอยากได้อีก1ดดีค่ะ
นกฮูก
นกฮูกเป็นสัตว์กินเนื้อกินพืชหรือกินทั้ง
สองอย่าง
เนื้อกินชัวร์ๆ
ชืดไม่แน่ใจ
นกฮูกเองไม่รู้เลยอย่าคิดอะไรง่ายๆอย่า
คิดเยอะกินเนื้อแล้วกันกินเนื้อกินเนื้อ
มันหนูกินหนูเป็นเหล็กสูงเองเอา 2 ตัว
ใหม่ให้จบอ่ะแรด
แรดกินเนื้อกินพืชกินทั้งสองอย่าง
กินพืชค่ะยินพืช
ใช่ค่ะน้ำจะกินพวกพุ่มไม้ต้นไม้
สายตาไม่ดีด้วยนะเนี่ยดีใจค่ะจะกินได้นะ
อีกหนึ่งตัวแม่แมว
แมวเป็นสัตว์กินเนื้อกินพืชหรือกินทั้ง
สองอย่างกินทั้ง 2 อย่างค่ะตัวไหมตัวกิน
ทุเรียนด้วยชัวร์หรอกินขนมด้วยกินข้าว
ด้วยกินปลาด้วยกินหมูด้วยหนู
ต้องกัน
ทำไมเหลยคู๋
แมวเนี่ยจริงๆแนวกินทั้ง 2 อย่างนะเหมือน
ครูพูดแต่เขาบอกว่าแมวเป็นสัตว์ที่กิน
เนื้อ
อ้าวแต่มันกินเหมือนไอ้นะเหมือนกับว่าแมว
เนี่ยต้องกินโปรตีน
อ่อนคือร่างกายถ้าไม่ได้เป็นโปรตีนแมวไม่
โอเคเพราะแต่คนไทยให้แมวกินข้าวๆผู้ชายตา
แมวต้องกินแล้วนะกินปลาย่างกินไก่ที่ทำ
อาหารแล้ว
โปรตีนจริงๆแมวไม่ได้อยากกินข้าวใช่ค่ะ
เขาบอกว่าแมวร้อยเปอร์เซ็นต์กินเนื้อย่าง
เสือก็จะกินพืชได้อันนี้ไม่รู้เนาะ
เขาบอกใครค่ะกูเองก็ดูที่บ้านให้กินอะไร
จะบัญชีแม้ว่ากินหญ้าเวลาปิวท้องแมวก็ไป
กินหญ้าไงนี่แล้วแต่เขาก็แมวเป็นสัตว์กิน
เนื้อแบบเนื้ออ่าคิดว่าเหมือนเสือจะให้
ชิดกันแข็งแรงต้องกินเนื้อใช่ผู้หญิงหมา
กินทั้ง 2 อย่างค่ะ
หากินทุกอย่างใช่ตอนแรกผู้หญิงคิดหมาเป็น
สัตว์กินเนื้อเหมือนๆเสือแต่ไม่ใช่นะหมา
กินทั้งสองอย่างกินเนื้อกินพืช
อยู่บ้านกินอะไรกินไอศครีมยินมีทุเรียนน
กินทุกอย่างจ่ายค่ะน้องวันนี้ก็อู้ครูเอ๋
เก่งมากนะคะนะรู้ว่าสัตว์แต่ละอย่างเนี่ย
มันเป็นสัตว์กินอะไรนะแต่ว่างั้นนะก็ผิด
ดินโอ๊ยกูกูเองคะผิดนิดหน่อยโอเค
นักเรียนผิดหรือถูกไม่เป็นไรเนาะเกมเกม
สบายๆฟังภาษาไทยนะคะแต่ว่าวันนี้เนี่ยคุย
กับกูอีกต้องไปแล้วนะคะแล้วเดี๋ยวเจอกัน
วีดีโอหน้าสวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบาย